all right our next speaker in addition
to being a growth strategist it was also
featured in the can film festival
documentary happy happily ever laughter
uh I think singing in intro uh ladies
and gentlemen uh please put your hands
together for charity hi I am charity
Wright golden I'm going to be talking to
you about the humanity of data today
here's a little snapshot of me I was so
cool to see like the linear with the
dates and all of this I'm a dactic
thinker thinking picture pictures
visualization so here is my little my
little map of me my family uh wife to
one man mother to two children I have uh
originally from Plant City which is the
winter strawberry capital of the world
and it's about 25 minutes from here
raised by a single mom who worked four
jobs seven days a week so I could have
opportunities that she didn't have um so
I literally showed up first day at
Barnard College Columbia University with
overalls pigtail braids hey y'all I'm
charity Wright so I bring a a uh a
Nuance perspective because stepping into
a culture that wasn't familiar to me
sparked this growth mindset and it's
been on fire ever since so my hope today
is being able to challenge some of the
uh cerebral that you all have this
Talent of IQ and I'll be able to bring a
little value ad with a bit of EQ so the
purpose of this monologue because you
can't ask me questions is I want you to
be people and I want you to have and
companies of Excellence optimization and
integrity
okay why I'm going to read to you
Integrity leading with integrity and
empathy requires vision and an
connection to your deepest self Carla
McLaren Shelley Francis says it takes
courage to create a meaningful life of
Integrity it also requires good company
good colleagues good Consultants good
people and practice so today we're going
to practice a little bit I promise to be
gentle um um and we're just going to
challenge a little bit of maybe the
under access Notions and and aspects of
ourselves to see if we can take growth
and take that mindset to the next level
I encourage each of you to grab Martha
Beck's book The Way of Integrity longer
quote there but we need to move on why
do I want to talk to you about this
about integrity because I want you to
build a life and a legacy that you are
proud of we are all going to make money
here you're here to learn you're here to
be a blessing to your family to your
friends to your community and then what
when you have all the money that you
could ever spend what do you want your
life what do you want your legacy to be
about so we're going to talk about that
today okay all right so Cherry this
sounds great yeah life Legacy and
integrity what do I have to do well
today I'm going to request your trust
trust is something is earned and we
haven't had that opportunity yet I
encourage you to request trust from
people in your life from your employees
instead of require it and I promise to
be gentle as I said because I'm married
to one of you my husband is a triple
Major engl uh excuse me computer science
Computer Engineering electrical
engineering Predictive Analytics
introvert engineer so again I'll be kind
be gentle and I'm going to ask you to
maybe take a break for 16 minutes and 52
seconds from looking outside to the
world analyzing it figure out which
approach is it descriptive prescriptive
diagnostic to the outside world and just
take a breath we're going to take a
couple and a few few moments to look on
the inside because to me when you do not
fully leverage all of the skills
strengths values that you were born with
raised with nature nurture you leaving
money on the table and I'm not
interested in that as a grow
strategist okay so your reaction may be
okay who is this who's this ch
like woo and that's okay but I'm going
to make a business case to you the when
you marry EQ with IQ longevity and
differentiation is the yield and as Ai
and other Technologies continue to be
more Dynamic and robust you have to
figure out a way to differentiate how
are you going to compete how are you
going to attract and retain Talent
innovate and continue to provide value
to your clients and grow it's really
important that instead of Chase Chase
Chase you say am I stewarding well
myself my time the people their talents
their perspectives am I optimizing that
right Excellence optimization Integrity
those are the kind of people
professional leaders and and Visionaries
that we need for this
space okay so this is my mission to show
you the value of marrying EQ with IQ
it's what I do in my practice um I want
you to bring your full selves your head
heart hands and and like let's get some
work done all right and I promise you
will be I'm taking a note from Tanya
yesterday with the baby Yoda the grou
and that this will be you so all right
I'm requesting your trust so together
Zoomies make sure you're taming in we're
going to take three deep breaths
together this is a practice and a ritual
that I want to encourage each of you to
bring into your homes your companies and
your community so here we go
inhale
exhale
exhale and last one
inhale
exhale okay it's really cool to hear you
all exhale for us all for just 14
minutes to maybe be on the same page for
us to slow down the ever ever moving
brains and to really tap back into that
and to connect
because the point of differentiation
that EQ plus IQ is that connectivity the
communication and being able to fully
leverage all that you and your team and
your community bring to the
table all right so the reason why I know
that this adds value is as a growth
strategist I've had my uh own practice
for six years been growing companies and
hopefully their people uh for the last
nine is there's kind of three reasons
why I see companies struggle and fail
and we don't have enough time to go deep
in all of this so we're going to focus
on the third but one is holes in the
infrastructure when you're starting out
and you're building a company you need
to bootstrap resources are limited you
got to be kind of Scrappy so there are
holes in your infrastructure maybe it's
legal maybe it's marketing maybe it's
your HR understandable because you're
just building that first level right
okay but then more resources come
because you're hustling you're doing the
thing you're operating authentically
with integrity and the second story
comes there's still holes third fourth
more over ahead more people what happens
when one day the hits the fan the
flood comes what happens the water comes
into that infrastructure that Holy
infrastructure and it cracks that
infrastructure this is not to scare you
this is to say as you were starting out
or if you find yourself right now hey
we've got holes here make a list figure
out a way we need to prioritize this and
check this off the list you can be
strategic about resources maybe you need
to hire a fraction CTO a fractional CMO
maybe you need to do this and share a
piece of the pie maybe you need to bring
Collective people to come on board with
you and share a piece of your company
with that to fill in those holes okay if
you're going to build a skyscraper you
got to have a firm foundation all right
the second thing is I often see
companies clients of M where they're
more concerned about comparing and
competing than operating with Integrity
that alignment of The Head and the Heart
right they're looking it's kind of fomo
it's our culture how many likes do you
have I get it too right like I'm
building a Global Network for women I I
it's not the I'm not Reinventing the
wheel here so I get it but what I'm
talking to you today we're going to get
it as we're Building Solutions is when
you operate from this place of Integrity
right head heart hands that alignment
and you activate that that's your point
of differentiation that's how you can
identify teammates that come alongside
you that come along and and sacrifice
time or maybe sacrifice a little bit of
salary because of that alignment these
are real things and when you go out into
the world with this is who we are what
we value what we're on a mission to do
you don't have to worry about your
competition do your competitive analyses
that's fine that's not what I'm talking
about but you come from a place of
authenticity and integrity activation of
that not worried last thing we're going
to talk about and more in depth today is
the underleveraged assets and really I
just mean your talent so whether you are
a business owner or maybe you're a
student right all the way from Norway
from Latifa right um I want to talk to
you about under leveraged assets I am
not interested again in leaving money on
the table I cannot tell you how often
these clients these brilliant Founders a
little bit of founder syndrome they get
so wrapped up in their Solutions and
their this and that that they're not
listening to the 24 yearold who has a
really brilliant idea or the executive
assistant that's been with them for 15
years and seeing every growth every
growth stage of that company I want you
to be aware and sit in a posture of
curiosity and humility and a growth
mindset that can come from anywhere so
we're going to go a little bit deeper
into that okay so the underlever assets
all right the uh famous Management
Consultant Peter Ducker says culture
still eats strategy for breakfast how
many of you have come up with like the
most brilliant strategy ever everyone
raise your hand go raise your hand yeah
strategies okay and you're like we spent
so much money and we got these such
brilliant people and look at their phds
and look at and and that's amazing my
brother's a PhD love all you
Geniuses if you don't take care of your
people if your culture is one of
intimidation fear or people cannot come
to you with an idea because you're going
to shut it down that culture will eat up
whatever strategy you put before you
cannot by yourself make an entire Legacy
happen it requires Community commitment
connectivity buyin communication so this
is why this matters marrying the IQ the
Brilliance in these tools oh my gosh you
guys are so smart you're so re I mean
just sitting back and listening I'm like
oh my God what are these formulas
brilliant okay I love it it's amazing
and you've got to fill in the gaps of
what your company your clients the world
needs
so you must go and get centered in a
place of purpose and Mission and
connectivity all right okay so I'm a
solution Sally at gr companies right so
if you can either get out a pen or your
notes app I would really like you guys
to take notes on this because it's four
points really quick all
right I want you to ask yourself why am
I doing this why am I getting up every
morning why am I uh trying to grow
company selling a company why what is
the purpose of your life and listen to
me this changes as you age and and and
all of that we got to have latitude and
Grace with ourselves Dr bne Brown talks
about living on a spectrum right where
you kind of oscillate here and there
cool I'm down for it but I want you to
write now what is the why of your life
Japanese culture is called iki guy it's
this really great Confluence of Four
Points what am I passionate about what
am I good at at what does the world need
and what can I get paid for because I
have an electricity bill how about you
so I want you to think about this and we
don't have enough time to go deep but
the eeky guy notion this point of
Confluence where you're thinking about
all that we have the world needs to get
done needs and activated and I want you
to try and bring it to this point of
Confluence because it matters when the
day is rough when someone quits when
investor backs out why are you doing
what you're doing are you trying to
change the world are you trying to say
uh provide for your family are you
trying to what is it don't be afraid of
that it's a big
question okay what what are the
principles or values I will root my life
and career in this is just a snapshot I
think it's a 100 words I think that's
true something about that I want you to
take a really quick I'm going to give
you 14 seconds I want you to take a look
at this list and whichever pop out about
five write them down
please 3
seconds okay Scott what's a value of
yours challenge challenge Stanton
boys love it Latifa
value tell me again achievement I love
it ma'am curios
curiosity curiosity okay Paul
valueing ah love that meaningful work
it's awesome it's really important that
you have this set this Central set of
values and when you're working with your
colleagues companies even seeking
investors seeking business partners
people are going to pay you you want to
have this conversation you want to be
able to make sure that people people are
on a similar page not exact we don't
need group think here but we want
similarities and if you see a value at
in Conflict if your business partner has
a value that's in conflict with yours
how are you going to handle that I want
you to think about that this is this is
deep stuff and it's worth the work
because when you connect on
values it's a mission guys it changes
the it changes the potential and the
possibility of what a company can do to
what a movement can do how data can
change and shape and impact the world
for good for
growth rooted in
values so how I'm going to read this
quote I thought it was so good so this
is about professional rituals start as
you mean to go on rituals are a natural
way to begin the day or the week or
really anything with intention
Beginnings provide employees time to
pause reflect and connect you can easily
take something you already do in the
morning with your employees and make it
a beginning of the week ritual remember
that a ritual is 100% intentional so
even something as simple as sending a
morning checkin email with intention at
the beginning of an each week can be
made into a ritual best case scenario
surround your experience and Magic by
opening and closing with ritual that's
from Eric keswin from rituals Road I
want to encourage you to figure out
rituals and rhythms with yourself with
your family or your community and your
company I want you to every month have
an all if you can control these
variables every month you need to have
an all hands with your company every
month and I want you to think of a
ritual of everybody all right let's
pitch out terrible ideas Jared's G
goingon to share oh this was like the
worst idea I ever had for analytics and
making a community again an environment
a culture of it's okay to make mistakes
because guess what we fall down we get
our butts back up we learn and we move
on so I want you to think about how to
create rituals of humor of connection a
rhythm for you I try to start my day by
activating five senses what do I want to
hear smell taste touch and what's the
fif
one see thank you um I want you to think
about a way to nourish yourself in the
morning and it might be in the middle of
the day right it's like okay I'm I had a
really bad client call I had a really
bad conversation I had to let somebody
go what are some rituals that you can
tap into those five senses that bring
you back to yourself that point of
connectedness of intentionality of focus
of Integrity you can make that a part of
your day and guess what when you set
that kind of example it gives people
permission to operate in the same way
with intentionality with Excellence
being optimized because they're
operating head heart hands right okay
last with whom Scott and I are actually
talking about this so all of my clients
I I'm sorry it's a little bit light here
but um the Clifton strengths assessment
if you have not done it go do it it is1
1999 I wish I had an affiliate link I
would be retired but this was such a
lifegiving thing and Mr Donn Clifton
says what will happen when we think
about what is wrong with people rather
than fixating on excuse me right with
people rather than fixating on what is
wrong with them that's a slip right in a
culture and Society where we're so
critical of ourselves our data our part
ners this or that what am I not doing
where am I failing I really want to I
want you to take this very objective and
have this as a data point about what am
I really good at this spoke a lot of
life into me I shared it on my first I
am strategic second belief three
ideation positivity and activator so
basically you give me something I
believe in I'm going to connect the
ideas and the people and you better
watch out so I want you to take this and
I want you to step boldly into this is
what I'm really good at I do not like
this fake it till you make it stuff I do
that is not authentic that is not you
operating with Integrity okay I want you
to find your business partners and your
uh when you hire to fill in the gaps
right like we need each other fill in
the gaps of our strengths okay it's
really really helpful it's very
lifegiving so in closing I want you to
bring your full self your head your
heart and your
hands your community and your team and I
want you to watch how your how your life
your community will change and grow for
the better all right I know sometimes as
super cerebral linear badass people that
it's hard for you to take a moment step
back from all of the data because it's
so numerous to take a breath or three
have a conversation and say hey I don't
feel like I'm in my Integrity right now
it feels like how I'm thinking about
this how I'm feeling about this business
partner this employee we don't seem to
share the same values and we can't seem
to get on the same page that's okay
that's authenticity because guess what
when you say no to
an or no thank you to an employee that
gives them an opportunity to go find the
yes that gives you space and bandwidth
for greatness for growth and so that's
uh basically what I have for uh go forth
it's been such an honor thank you so
[Applause]
much